[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bonsoir bonsoir
mais oui ce soir je vais raconter une
histoire à nicolas et appâts pradel une
histoire qu'ils aiment beaucoup qui vit
du débit mon échelle mais au début du
début du tibet du
boss
wasquehal a une histoire oui une
nouvelle histoire de la petite
philippine et de son lapin blanc
d'accord
un instant je me pose
là
écoutez bien philippines et sont amis le
lapin blanc vivaient très heureux dans
leur maison à la campagne
au milieu de leur grand jardin plein de
fleurs et de frères qui s'ennuie pas
tibi divine dit appelez philippines en
jouant du tambour
et petit bibi qui était devenu un gros
tbilissi temps il avait mangé le phrase
trotel content et satisfait derrière
elle
mais un jour alors qu'il faisait le tour
de leur jardin
tu me dises tibi du tibet du rhône à
très fort le lapin blanc
tibi qui a mangé mais pâle fraises route
philippines elle aussi très en colère a
pas sur son tombeau
[Musique]
faut pas se mettre en colère c'est très
bien il y avait de quoi toute une rangée
de phrase avait été grignoté qu'est ce
qui se fait là il se cacher derrière un
arbre et attendirent
bientôt un animal moustachu noir gris et
blanc avec une jolie queue en panache
areva
annonce aloi à papa loi
car derrière lui il y avait 1 2 3 4 et
sainte petit loire
timidité vue du s'écria le lapin blanc
en s'élançant courageusement mais les
lois très vif prirent chacun une fraise
rouge et se sauvèrent
philippides le lapin blanc restèrent
tout étonné dans leurs beaux jardins et
fort soucieux
qui me dit tu es des tribus du centre
après ces villes en loire s'écria le
lapin blanc
ils ne sont pas vilain pensait
philippines pourquoi ne serait-il pas
nos amis
je lis et loire ans ils sont amusants
ils peuvent bien grignoter quelques
phrases et voilà les enfants histoire
est terminée vous a plu havok et bien je
vous donne le livre merci maintenant je
vais me mettre dans ma bibliothèque
à présent nous allons y
chers petits
bonne nuit les enfants
fait deux pour un
[Musique]
tibi kebede kebede ma parole mais c'est
le lapin blanc mêlant patron c'est moi
nounours
je vous ai bien notre peu allons en
route gros farceur bogny des enfants
allez vite vous coucher le foot pour
[Musique]
oh
e